-You guys, former
President Donald Trump's
second impeachment trial
began today.
The House impeachment managers
laid out powerful evidence
of his guilt,
while most Republican
senators signaled
that they have no interest
in holding him accountable.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The nation is currently facing
a series of calamities
unprecedented in our lifetime.
It's so bad that
Jake Tapper's brow furrows
have started encroaching
on the rest of his face.
He's starting to look like
a Shar Pei with gravitas.
And, in the short term,
things are only getting worse.
Millions are unemployed and the
economy is still stalling,
the vaccine rollout
is still chaotic,
even as more contagious
COVID strains are spreading,
not to mention rising poverty
and child hunger,
while millions face
the threat of eviction
or losing
their health insurance.
Oh, and also,
the former president
is facing
a second impeachment trial
for inciting
a violent insurrection
that ransacked the Capitol
and sought
to overthrow democracy.
And I know I'm starting to sound
like an African grey parrot
who was left alone
with a collection
of Morrissey records,
but this is where we are.
[ Squawk ]
If you're a person with any
sort of platform right now,
you could spend any amount
of time you want
covering any of those topics.
Or, if you're Fox News,
you could spend precious
minutes, in prime time,
covering whatever the [bleep]
this is.
-Jonathan Kay is a senior editor
at the online magazine
Quillette.
He did a throwaway tweet,
revealing that,
for the last three months,
he'd accidentally
been washing his hair
with his dog's shampoo.
And, next thing you know,
big-time Hollywood star
Seth Rogen
and small-time lefty hack
Keith Olbermann
and the rest of the
Blue Checkers
were pounding on him.
-Yes, that's what Fox News
was talking about last night --
dog shampoo.
You know, the stuff Ted Cruz
uses to wash his beard.
[ As Cruz ]
I also use Frontline.
Got to keep those ticks away.
I have no idea what this is
about and I have
no interest in learning.
All I know is,
the smaller the story
Fox News is focusing on,
the bigger the story
they're ignoring is.
If you ever tune in
to "Fox & Friends"
and they're talking about,
I don't know,
whether vanilla ice cream
is going to be canceled
for being too white,
just know the story on CNN
is probably...
But that's what the GOP
is all about now --
inane culture war bull[bleep]
There's not time
for insurrections or COVID
when a poor man catches flak
for complaining
the font that said "for Pets"
was too small to read,
while ignoring that there was
a picture of a dog
on the bottle.
I lied. I did know what the
story was about. What can I say?
I follow big-time Hollywood star
Seth Rogen on Twitter.
And if you're wondering
what incredibly cruel thing
he said when he saw the "I've
been using dog shampoo" tweet,
a tweet so cruel that Fox News
did a segment on it,
it was this...
[ Laughter ]
I get it.
You see a tweet like that,
the next thing you know,
you're stress-eating
a box of human snacks.
[ Laughter ]
This isn't a political movement
with policy ideas.
It's about culture.
They want you to think antifa's
coming to your house
with migrant caravans
to take away your guns
and your dog
and your human shampoo
with the picture of a dog on it.
In fact, that's barely
an exaggeration.
That's their actual
argument now --
the Democrats
are just as responsible
for inciting violence
as Trump is
because Democrats
want immigration reform.
-Democrats are arguing
that Trump welcomed and incited
a violent incursion
into the Capitol.
When it is they
who are enticing illegals
to bust through our borders,
exploit our resources,
and commit crimes.
-Exploit our resources?
Do you think immigrants
are coming to America
to open a copper mine?
You sound like a desert warlord
from the "Mad Max"
Cinematic Universe.
Who is your guest
for this segment...
Did you guys know his name
was the Doof Warrior?
Yeah, I mean,
I know a lot of you did,
but I bet the rest of you
just thought his name
was something like
Flame-Throwing Guitar Guy.
That's how kickass
"Mad Max" was, as a movie.
They give him the dorkiest name
they could come up with
and the movie still rocks.
It's like, instead of Bane,
Tom Hardy's Batman villain
had been called Dr. CPAP or...
[ As Bane ]
Bad news, Batman.
[ Laughter ]
Schmagillicutty.
Also, you used "busting
through our borders" already.
You got Donald Trump elected
on those fish tales
and I thought we made it
very clear
that GOP platforms are like
stand-up comedy jokes --
once you use one on TV,
you can never use it again.
It's why prayer in schools,
explicit rap lyrics,
and Murphy Brown's pregnancies
were used in one election cycle
and then never again.
You have four years
to come up with a new way
to terrify
the people of Florida.
Maybe claim the DNC
is trying to ban fan boats
and jean shorts
that go to the ankle.
What's that?
The GOP's already doing that
and it will work
and Lou Dobbs will suddenly be
our next president?
[ Laughing ]
Okay, man.
Politics, you share are goofy.
But, really, the truly
galling part is the idea
that Democrats are somehow
enticing migrants to come here
and "commit crimes" when Trump
is under investigation
for, last I checked,
I don't know,
30 different crimes?
In fact, he's already confessed
to illegally using his charity
as a personal checkbook
and he was
an unindicted co-conspirator
in the Michael Cohen case,
you know, the one where
he secretly paid hush money
during a presidential campaign
to cover up an affair
with a porn star.
Remember that episode?
That was way back in Season 1,
when Trump still had Marcel.
The Manhattan D.A.
and New York attorney general
are both investigating Trump
and his businesses,
the D.A. in Fulton County
has been looking into whether
to open an investigation,
and, yesterday, the Georgia
secretary of state's office
said it opened
an official inquiry
into Trump's
unhinged phone call,
attempting to bully
Georgia election officials
into throwing out legal ballots
and overturning the results.
And I'm no lawyer, but it almost
certainly seems like a crime.
One former federal prosecutor
told CNN it's...
And even that is
a generous interpretation.
Trump doesn't talk in code.
He's like that idiot who calls
a weed dealer and uses code
and then, uses the real word,
to make sure the code was right.
"Hey, Scott, what's up?
You got any, uh, tickets
for the, uh, reggae concert?
That's weed, right? Because
like the reggae guys like weed.
Hello? Hello?"
[ Laughter ]
In response,
Trump spokesman Jason Miller,
the guy who looks like
he swapped heads
with a Pez dispenser,
said it was actually the fault
of Brad Raffensperger,
the Georgia secretary of state,
for taking the call,
in the first place.
Man, where does Trump find these
fine purveyors of pretzel logic?
"Look, Your Honor, if you don't
want my client stabbing people,
then Cuisinart
shouldn't sell knives.
Oh, oh, my bad.
Wrong case.
Uh, any chance Cuisinart
sells guns?
Oh, I think you're --
I think you're probably
going to jail.
[ Laughter ]
It's not terrible.
They have libraries."
This guy is under investigation
for actual crimes,
let alone
the impeachable offense
of inciting an insurrection
against the U.S. Capitol.
The least we can do is bar him
from ever holding office again.
Instead, Republicans and their
allies in right-wing media
are engaged
in a ridiculous attempt
to equate Democrats
encouraging peaceful protests
with Trump spending
several months
feeding his unhinged base lies
about the election
and fantasies
of violent retribution.
-I want to interview Chuck.
-[ Laughing ]
I want to interview Joe Biden.
I want to interview Kamala.
I want
to interview Pelosi.
I want to interview
Maxine Waters.
I want to interview Cory Booker,
Eric Holder.
I got a whole list.
Would you consider looking
at my list?
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, I'll be glad
to look at it.
If the House managers want
to call one witness,
the defense is going to call
all the people you name,
and then some.
The impeachment in the House
took place without a hearing,
without one witness
being called,
and without a lawyer
for the president
of the United States.
You can't get a traffic ticket,
based on the procedures
they used to impeach
President Trump.
-Okay, first of all, have you
ever gotten a traffic ticket?
You can get one for anything.
One time, I got in my car
and found a $20 ticket
on the windshield
for something called...
In New York, we have something
called alternate side parking,
which basically means
you get a traffic ticket,
unless you can solve a riddle.
Also, Sean,
congrats on your list.
You sound like a toddler
talking to a mall Santa.
[ As Hannity ]
We look at my list, please?
I want a Tonka truck
and a Nerf gun
and a regular-shaped head.
[ Gravelly voice ]
Listen, kid,
I'm not really Santa,
but I can tell you,
you're probably stuck
with that head, bub.
Now, most people aren't buying
these asinine arguments.
A majority of Americans --
56% in a recent ABC News poll --
want Trump convicted and barred
from ever holding office again,
so cowardly Republicans are
hiding behind a new argument --
impeaching a former president
is somehow unconstitutional.
-I want to read
this very revealing quote
from Senator James Lankford.
He says..
-Oh, you're locked down?
You're supposed to be the jury!
Once again, these guys think
the standards that apply
to everyone else
somehow doesn't apply to them.
I mean, none of us could
get away with just announcing
how we feel about a case
before the trial starts.
I tried that one time
when I got called to jury duty.
"I'm sorry, Your Honor, but,
I feel strongly that,
if you burn yourself
with hot McDonald's coffee,
you deserve it.
I will never turn on Ronald!"
The judge found me in contempt
and sentenced me
to three months' house arrest
with a painting
of a sea captain.
That was on network television.
[ Laughter ]
Second, the idea that impeaching
a former president
is unconstitutional
is ridiculous.
It doesn't say that anywhere
in the Constitution.
If you manage to flee
the scene of a crime
before the cops can catch you,
you don't get
to automatically go free.
If that was the case, Trump
would've finished his speech
and then immediately jumped
in a white Ford Bronco.
And then, today, one of the
House impeachment managers,
Congressman Jamie Raskin,
made a powerful
and deeply emotional case
and he argued in a convincing
and clear-cut way
that this impeachment was,
in fact, constitutional,
using both historical evidence
and also common sense.
-Their argument is that, if you
commit an impeachable offense
in your last few weeks
in office,
you do it with
constitutional impunity.
You get away with it.
In other words,
conduct that would be
a high crime and misdemeanor
in your first year as president
and your second year
as president
and your third
year as president
and for the vast majority
of your fourth year
as president,
you can suddenly do
in your last few weeks in office
without facing
any constitutional
accountability at all.
This would create
a brand-new January exception
to the Constitution
of the United States of America.
-Yeah, the founders didn't
intend to write in an exemption
where you can commit
whatever crimes you want
in your last month in office.
It's called the transition,
not the Purge.
This isn't the last week
of middle school,
where every teacher
shows a movie
while they Google
"vacation Caribbean cheap"
and the French teacher
tells you all the good swears.
I don't remember
George Washington
spending his last month
in office
walking around D.C. with an ax,
chopping down every damn
cherry tree he could find.
"It's pie night, bitches!"
The House impeachment managers
also laid out
the timeline of events
on January 6th
and Trump's involvement
in those events
with truly shocking
video evidence
that, I have to say,
was compelling,
just to see it all
laid out again,
because our memories
are so short now.
I mean, I don't even remember
who won the Super Bowl.
Tim Brody?
Was there a guy named Brunk?
Like there was a Grunk,
or maybe it was a tree
[ Laughter ]
who only said, "Grunk"?
It was a violent insurrection
that injured 140 police officers
and tried
to overthrow democracy.
Congress was there and the rest
of us saw it on TV.
The facts are clear as day,
as Raskin explained.
-Our case is based
on cold, hard facts.
-That's right, the impeachment
case is built on facts,
and the defense's case is built
on wishes and dreams
and Sean Hannity's
fantasy list of witnesses,
which I'm betting includes
some fictional characters, too.
[ As Hannity ]
I want to call Chuck Schumer,
Nancy Pelosi, Cory Booker,
Wanda Maximoff, the Mandalorian,
and the Doof Warrior.
I want to know what he doofed
and when he doofed it.
We all saw what happened.
It's plain to anyone
who cares to see it.
The president's supporters
stormed the Capitol
after he spent months
feeding them unhinged lies
about the election
being stolen from them,
culminating in a speech
in which he directed them
to fight and show strength
by marching down to the Capitol
and interfering in the lawful
counting of electoral votes,
all while he watched
and cheered them on.
At this point, we have
to conclude simply that,
if Republicans won't hold Trump
accountable for doing that,
then they support it and,
if given the chance,
they'll do it again.
Impeachment should be
the bare minimum
for inciting a violent sedition.
If you ask me,
Trump should be...
-Washing his hair
with his dog's shampoo.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.